[Music]  hi I'm Stephen Colbert and I'm hosting  the 2017 Emmy Awards The Late Show host  will be emceeing the show for the first  time ever he has won nine Emmys though  for his work on The Colbert Report and  The Daily Show hey has anybody seen my  tuxedo never mind I know where I left it  [Music]  there we go  stephen has been a shooting promos for  the awards and you just know he'll bring  that famous wait to his opening  monologue you know there's been a lot of  hacking this year so to ensure that the  winners remain top secret I've had my  assistant place all the envelopes in  this giant safe you okay in there  no only a couple more weeks besides  hosting he's also a nominee for the Late  Show with Stephen Colbert audience a lot  of these confessions are jokes made up  on my writers we just hope comes  September 17th on CBS he avoids a  wardrobe malfunction okay he's got my  pants  [Music]  you